hallo leute hier wieder einmal wann und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir endlich
den t shirts auch wodka trinkt und falls
jetzt in den letzten drei jahren unter
mond gelebt habe hier ist er
ich würde mal so sagen gehört definitiv
auf die top ten von meiner cocktail sie
ballern liste es ist nicht nur ein mini
sind wir ehrlich es ist auch eine mut
ein bisschen mich gefragt hat ob ich das
mal einem wie schmeckt nach machen soll
habe ich immer nicht daran gedacht das
ist ja ein richtiger klippel und ich sag
mal so den trinkt den wieder macht der
ist sogar richtig kreativ und klingt gar
nicht mal so scheiße also seid ihr
bereit für wie schmeckt der tut's auch
wodka cocktail aus dem ihm trotz erfolgs
hauptsache ich habe mir beim einkaufen
erstmal den fettesten basilikum aller
zeiten geholt habe ich also gesehen und
dachte mir so klar mach ich beste und
ich musste unbedingt die amarena kirsch
am arena ist echt mal allerliebste
eisbecher eine amarena kirsch und damit
wir das alles schön zubereiten kann
wandern wir jetzt über eine umbaupause
ist das nicht sondern eine pause für das
licht leute es gibt eine sache die ich
heute ganz dringend braucht und zwar
einen starken cocktail um die letzte
[Musik]
liebe diese serie zu sie andere vorbei
grund nummer zwei um sich zu betrinken
bald sind europawahlen und ich werde
euch nicht sagen wen ihr wählen sollte
ich sage euch nur wenn ihr nicht wählen
sollte und dafür schaut euch bitte
dieses video an
ich verlege euch das unten in der video
beschreibung ich sag mal so er zeigt
welche parteien vielleicht in den
letzten jahren ein bisschen verpackt
haben ein ganz kleines bisschen so nach
und bekommt er den drachen in dem clip
sieht man als erstes wie sie in einer
schale eine zerquetschte
ich bin hier mit zum kammer einrichten
guten tag
[Musik]
okay wir ignorieren das jetzt gewittern
zeit auch nur ein paar blitze die vom
himmel kommen weil gott böse auf uns
gegen kehlen zu schicken
bestimmt gibt es wieder einen coolen
live act wie man dies so schälen kann
dass es überhaupt nicht eklig wird
okay wir müssen es in scheiben schneiden
ein kopf scheibe und dann testet ihr wir
immer noch nach biebrich und zwei
scheiben müssen wir uns auf bewahren die
werden jetzt zerquetscht
ich brauche vielmehr die erde typ von
der buecher.de so axel weber ich bin so
gestresst von meiner ehe und meinen
kindern
der saurier am tag zum wodka quetschte
den shake shake that i
und jetzt kommt der moment auf den wir
alle gewartet haben werden hier banka um
wodka
jetzt kommt melonen likör und ich habe
zwei gefunden zuerst habe ich den
gefunden und da hat es mich genervt dass
es aber rot ist weil ihrer ist grün und
der ist halt farbloser wir nehmen den
farblosen weilrod verrechnen the verge
of mellon
[Musik]
es ist sogar wasser also können wir auch
einen teelöffel zucker nehmen
und jetzt kommt wirklich das absolute
finale ein esslöffel wasser
ein geruch von hand bekomme ich sofort
los auf matches mit kessen
das ist falsch
[Musik]
mir fällt gerade auch mit ein bisschen
geschlagen
wer hat bock auf diesen cocktail so
erinnert ihr euch an die kniescheiben
vom anfang
und hier ist der leute der tu charts auf
wodka wodka trinkt hurra die welt geht
nun endlich unter attacke in den nacken
brust wie schmeckt der t shirts auf
wodka
sorry lieber gott ich werde weniger
trinken brautleute
oh ha der erste geschmack danach
schmeckt man ein bisschen melone an man
spürt das ist ein bisschen scharf sein
soll
sie gibt auch so seinen eigenen
geschmack dazu ich bin jetzt ich das
sofort nach kiwi schmeckt und wenn man
dann kurz matrix ankommt so dieses wodka
warme gefühl in der brust was ich bin
nicht leiden kann das ja gesagt aber
dieser million millionen und die leute
das ist die combo o mein gott beim
nächsten drei cocktails
ich werde richtig abreißen ich habe
schon gesehen dass sturm bei ling space
box da war weil so ein format kopiert
haben darauf gewartet dass das gewitter
so richtig rein bricht und da war freddy
richtig gut der hat das müsst ihr euch
unbedingt folge allerdings ihr euch auch
unten in der video beschreibung
da hat er richtig abgerissen so leute
jetzt wisst ihr wie man den t shirts auf
wodka wort gemacht und ich hoffe ihr
hattet spaß beim zuschauen wenn ja dann
gibt mir einen tag nach oben abonniert
main kanal patient nicht getan habt
folgt mir auftritt folgt mir
auftakterfolg mehr auf instagram twitter
folgt mir bis zum 1
haustüren ich habe gerade den blitz
gesehen und eine sekunde später war das
sound zu hören das heißt es ist direkt
hier ist es dann ja